journalists come in in the morning and
they're given a list of the stories that
were trending online overnight which is
why you know these poor poor buggers
they come in to work and they're like
right write something about this who is
this i don't know it's an american
celebrity she was on some kind of series
that you've not heard of and what's
happened to her i don't know she's
breaking it with a boyfriend who's her
boyfriend i don't know it doesn't matter
just write something
rob orchard welcome in the show
nice to be here chris nice to be here
thanks very much for inviting me my
pleasure how do you describe what you do
for work
uh so i'm an editor uh i edit a
beautiful quarterly news magazine called
delayed gratification uh which i
launched uh with my co-editor marcus
back in 2010 with an idea of providing
sort of an antidote to knee-jerk uh
twitter-driven
news reporting uh which doesn't give
journalists enough time to really get to
grips with stories so we kind of go the
opposite way once every three months we
produce a beautiful magazine news
magazine which looks back over the big
events of the quarter uh with the
benefit of hindsight and asked the
question of what happened next
so that's slow journalism that you've
coined
yeah yeah so i wouldn't i'm not going to
claim ownership of it it's um you know a
lot of people have been talking about it
for a long time but i think ours is the
first
magazine or as was the first magazine to
put a flag in the sound and say yes this
is a slow journalism magazine and the
idea is it's a bit like um slow food and
slow travel right so taking your time to
do something of quality and and kind of
providing a counter a counterbalance to
sort of
life getting terribly speedy and and
news getting terribly speedy and
everything getting terribly speedy
what's the big difference between slow
and fast journalism
well there's all sorts of different
things so what tends to happen in terms
of the way that we we we process our
news is that um
it's coming at us from all directions
you know it's on our phones it's kind of
quite often the first thing that we do
in the morning right instead of turning
to our loved one we turn on our phones
we check and make sure nothing horrible
has happened overnight um and lasting at
night as well and throughout the day and
on our socials and it's it's kind of
this white noise of news
and what what tends to happen as well is
that it moves in in kind of cycles so
you get an intense concentration on a
massive story for a few days
and then suddenly the news agenda moves
on
and you're quite often left with the the
sort of the feeling
of not having really got to grips with
what the story was or or wanting to know
what happened next um but but you know
the news cycle feeds on novelty and so
it's kind of constantly moving on so to
take an example um
afghanistan we were all glued to the
story um over the summer in august um
august 15th the fall of kabul and the
kind of the few days leading up to that
and the few few days after that
but since then the coverage of what's
been happening in afghanistan has
completely fallen off a cliff um and we
happen to have in the next issue a very
um a very well written a very well
considered piece from a female
journalist who's been there for the last
year and has who continued very bravely
continued didn't leave with everybody
else stayed there um and has got this
incredible 6000 word read for us really
getting to grips with what's happened in
the country since then
so i suppose
when it works well what it is is you
open up the the magazine or you know
wherever you read it
you open up the magazine
and you think god you have that story
what the hell happened to that i
remember that and we tell you you know
and in amongst that we also tell you the
stories that you missed we have this
kind of slightly cheesy line of the
stories either missed or others missed
or mistold um so this idea of in the
kind of the heat of you know like 24 7
rolling news there's there's stuff that
gets missed and there's stuff that gets
that gets put out there uh wrongly so
this is ideally in his best form it's an
antidote to that
i remember doing an as level
in
social media
no sorry in media studies and sociology
so a quarter of
an a level
in media studies and even then i
remember learning about
on 9 11
the way that certain companies
executives said it's a good day for bad
news and they released tons and tons of
weird murky stories that they just
needed to kick out into the press
because they knew it was going to be
relegated to page 105 and it didn't
really matter so that's super that's
before social media that's before
twitter that's before rapid
smartphone delivery for information and
disinformation and misinformation and
even then people were able to play these
games and they were able to work with
the if it bleeds it leads
um seductiveness for the press to look
at the things that are in front of them
and there's now even more
it sounds like
we're delivered the front end of the
story because that's where the novelty
lies but we never close the loop around
what actually happened in the story
because
who cares about closure all that anyone
wants to know about is what's new
yeah i mean it's it's it's very easy to
get very cynical about it and obviously
there are tons of brilliant journalists
and brilliant news organizations and one
thing that i'm always trying to be
careful about is not in any way to say
that like we are the answer because
we're not we're a small team we make a
beautiful magazine comes out once every
three months if you relied on it for
finding out what's happening on you know
what was going on in the world then you
know
like three months after the fact you'd
be like oh wow so biden got in yeah
there's a there's a panda there's a
pandemic on that's why everyone's been
dying there's a pandemic going on so
we're not we're not the answer in that
sense there are tons of you know skilled
and talented journalists out there doing
amazing work and there are people doing
kind of follow-up stories however that's
not that's not the way that most of the
news that we receive works
and part of that is as you say it's
novelty it's if it bleeds it leads which
is kind of you know from time immemorial
that is you know how journalism has
worked but part of it is also
the economics right
so as you have moved away from
you you you know you get up in the
morning and you go and buy your
particular newspaper you spend money on
it and you know you kind of take it and
dissect it and so on and the the editors
make their best guess as as to what will
be interesting and useful to you
you move to a time when news is largely
free and has been expected to be free
um and
the way to monetize it is by
you know using the data of the people
who are buying it and you know feeding
them up very invasive very targeted
advertising
and that kind of militates away from
considered journalism right because
actually
if you're only measuring value in terms
of clicks
then the sensible thing to do is not to
you know it's not to commission a six
thousand word considered piece which you
know a team of editors work on with a
brave journalist and you know you're
gonna get something really interesting
the sensible thing to do is to bang out
a couple of hundred words of nonsense uh
with some sort of sly reference to a
celebrity who's in vogue at the moment
put on a provocative headline and just
kind of pump it out and pump out 20 or
30 of those you know a day that's you
know because then you get the clicks and
then you get the advertising and then
you can fund things and so on so there's
something
rotten about the system
there's an interesting thing that i mean
in recent years i have seen the pendulum
start to swing back a little bit as it
always does right
which is pay walls
and people putting up you know payables
and and demanding money for their
journalism and thank god right because
we got into a really bleak period when
we launched this this magazine it was
you know like the only way forward that
people saw was in digital um that print
was there digital and um had to be free
i'd be free and you had to get mass
and that was really really kind of scary
because we were educating an entire
generation of people to expect that they
should get you know all of their news
for free even though good news cost
money sam harris has a point around this
that he says the entire internet made a
price estimation error
in terms of how much it values content
podcasts shouldn't be free everyone
that's listening to this right now
should be paying me for my time
everyone should and they should be
paying every every other podcast for as
well when you think about the amount of
value and pleasure that you get and how
engaging it is and how awesome that
platform is that's just one platform and
then talk about the best follow that you
have on twitter and then think about the
best blogger that you follow that just
writes because they like to do it and
the best newsletter that you subscribe
to and yeah people are picking up the
scraps with affiliate deals and maybe
they've got a members area where you can
pay for more content and maybe blah blah
blah like freemium model thin end of the
wedge [ __ ] but
the bottom line is that when we began
the internet when we began content
creation on the internet we misjudged
the entire universe misjudged
what you should be paying for and what
you should expect for free and sadly now
because of anchoring bias there is
that genie can't go back in the bottle
you cannot do that there is
anchoring bias is precisely what people
are doing with gated content they're
saying you still get the show for free
but you pay for more
as opposed to this is what you could
have got and now you have to pay to get
it it's all about avoiding the anchoring
bias but yeah i i think that
the perverse incentives that
de-incentivize people
from writing good pieces of long
journalism that would have taken ages
versus can you believe what khloe
kardashian wore last night here's a
photo of her with no makeup on going to
the whatever that's going to get shared
around and that'll trend so yeah of
course well it's even more insidious
than that so it's also um you know in in
certain news organizations what happens
is is journalists come in the morning
and they're given a list of the stories
that were trending online overnight you
know kind of the things that are out
there in the ether people were talking
about which is why
you know these poor
poor buggers you know they they come in
to work and they're like right write
something about this who is this i don't
know it's an american celebrity she was
on some kind of series that you've not
heard of ryan and what's happened to her
something i don't know she's breaking up
with a boyfriend who's her boyfriend i
don't know it doesn't matter just write
something
so you know at the bottom end the the
other thing that happens with this of
course and you're actually right that
there's i mean it's not a difficult
argument fundamentally is it to say that
um you know when you're talking about
journalism where you're sending people
to difficult and scary places to um you
know to be put into situations that you
wouldn't want to be put into on your
behalf so you can get information that's
that should be a fairly easy sell but
the other thing that happens of course
is that
um
as
as the number of media multiplier right
so as you kind of bust outside of the
established media which in many ways was
very very very good because it empowers
a lot of kind of smaller producers to to
do some interesting things and to
experiment but as you do that
and as their you know economic clout
comes down and down and down and as they
sort of hemorrhage cash there's fewer
opportunities for journalists to take
you know what was traditional journalism
so in this country for example what
would happen is you would
you know you'd start at an entry level
job on a local newspaper
and you'd frantically work away
hopefully some nice editor would take
you under their wing and sort of knock
some of the the rough corners off rough
edges off your writing and so on you'd
start writing pieces and trying to send
them to the nationals and eventually you
get a couple placed and then eventually
you might get something you know like
you know at the nationals and then you
work your way up there was a there was a
there was a kind of a ladder that you
could climb it kind of made sense right
and so what you end up there with is is
proper training and you know proper
experience and you can do that in a
context in which you can make enough
money to survive that sounds like a good
way to fund journalism which as we all
know is incredibly important to a stable
society right and to democracy but the
problem is now there's so few
there's no local news jobs local news is
basically dead has been killed by the
internet um
and there's very few opportunities at
the kind of the bigger establishment
organizations so you've still got all of
these people wanting to become
journalists still loads and loads of
people desperate to kind of go into that
they come out the other side and they
realize there's nothing for them to go
into and so then what they have to do is
they have to find some sort of back door
so there's the possibility they could
launch a podcast it might take off it
won't it might you know or they could
launch their own magazine it might take
off it won't it might you know and you
sort of you're you're hollowing out the
whole ecosystem and what you end up with
is the kind of the few opportunities
that there are there
tend not to be for the the better sort
of kind of interesting journalism they
tend to be this thing where you're just
turning the wheel to to keep the whole
shorted process going talk to me about
the difference between first and being
right i heard you talk about the amanda
knox story as a really good example of
this
the amanda knox story was fascinating so
it was this um
you know it was the re-trial of amanda
knox
uh for the murder of meredith kircher
in perugia
that's right yeah and um
so
this was uh this was a highly attended
court event in perugia
and all the world's major news
organizations were there there's these
extraordinary photos
of you know these banks and banks of of
people kind of watching the story
and um the daily mail had prepared two
news stories
uh one for if the the verdict went one
way and one for if it went the other way
and there was something that happened
maybe
somebody in the court misheard something
um you know it was guilty but it was
guilty to something else to a lesser
charge of slander rather than murder um
and
the button was pushed and the wrong news
story went up online because as we know
at the retrial amanda knox's the guilty
verdict was overturned and she was she
was ended up subsequently being released
and so this story goes up on the uh
world's single biggest english language
news site
which is um it is diametric opposite of
the truth
and you know this sort of thing has
always happened right because news
organizations they've always prepared
you know for eventualities you think
about elections you know there's uh
there's famous examples in the past of
people just being certain the election
was going to go one way and they
published their front story with x1 and
y wins
um and the thing that they got into
trouble
with uh the the mail was that there was
quite a lot of kind of elaborated
color there was quite a lot of
elaborated quotes that went in there as
well
and of course
was so i think there was a thing about i
need to be careful to get this right but
i think there was a thing about the the
the reaction um of uh of um
of knox and and of the family and i
think also um there was a quote from a
court official which i think was not
correct
and so
you know you have this you have this
very weird situation where this this
this wrong story kind of goes up and you
can completely understand why you get to
that point right because
getting stories out first means that
when lots and lots of people searching
for them
that's the story that they land on right
so people all around the world were
interested in this verdict and they you
know they wanted to know so there's this
incredible pressure to get the story out
first and obviously the people that
wanted to get it right
but they they kind of like they pushed
the wrong button and this went up it's
only up for a couple of minutes and then
they put the correct story up um uh
and you know if the verdict had been you
know what they thought it was
then that would have been you know part
of the the record of this event for the
rest of history even though stuff in it
was not kind of correct
so that's that's a weird thing you know
this this need for speed in this hyper
hyper hyper speedy knee jerk news
environment
means that we're kind of built for um
for error kind of creeping in and then
more than that and this is not what i'm
sort of suggesting in in this case
particularly but you know the whole
ecosystem is built up for for spreading
disinformation and misinformation very
very rapidly around the world you know
what it's like it reminds me of the
algorithmic trading companies on wall
street that moved their exchanges closer
moved their offices closer to the
exchanges to gain half a millisecond
that's right that's right and you know
because it matters right because the
economics of it are such that
if you get that story out first then
you're higher in the google rankings
which means more people link to you and
i mean i know the algorithm is changing
all the time but you know uh but you
know you you you're notion you're gonna
get higher up which means you can get
more clicks which means you can charge
more for the advertising which means at
a time when people aren't prepared to
pay for news you can still continue to
fund your organizations but i mean if
you sat down to construct
a kind of a news ecosystem from scratch
you know it wouldn't be that
what else are the press getting wrong at
the moment
i'm very low to criticize the press
because
i think that by and large um
the press is kind of comprised of
editors and journalists who are just
trying to do their best
and trying to get the truth out there
and of course you know my magazine you
know
one way we've talked about it is we're
slightly the kind of
we're the seagulls following the trawler
right because we're not you know we're
not breaking the news the the the slogan
down the spine of all of our issues is
last the breaking news so we're kind of
following along behind and you know we
get to we get to look at what has
happened and then we get to kind of ask
people to take a broader view on it and
there are interesting things around that
so you know one of the things that often
happens is
um when people are interviewed about an
event when it's just happened and
sometimes when it's still happening
still unfolding behind them
they tend to give a very different
reaction understandably to a few months
down the line when they've had a chance
to consider and put things in
perspective you know when they're
standing in front of the burning
building trying to process
what's happened
there's a very different reaction to you
know three months down the line okay i
think about it so people are selecting
for witnesses and for statements and for
reactions from people and commentators
and opinion pieces they're selecting for
a very particular type of opinion
well that's right so it is the opinion
that you get immediately and also
because the media moves you know uh on
mass around certain stories you also get
things so i remember going to salisbury
three months after the poisoning
and um it's actually my my hometown and
uh just kind of walking around talking
to people and they're like
god there's endless journalists and you
know people were almost scared to go
into the town center because they would
just be stopped like hi i'm from cnn i'm
bbc can i you know kind of get some
words for me how are you feeling i'm
feeling fine just [ __ ] off it's just
like my entire town is now just
journalists and like potentially some
novichok so uh
yeah so yeah
so that's you know that's that's another
kind of quirk of it but no as i said
sorry i'm i'm very lucky to criticize
journalists um i think in an ideal world
um we would find
and i think you know i think slowly
we're getting there because i think
these pay walls seem to be working and
actually a wonderful example is the
guardian so the guardian was losing
money handover fists for for many many
years
and um they took this kind of very grown
up decision to
say to their readers what we do costs
money
and you need to support us if you want
it we'll keep giving it we'll do it free
because we want reach and we think our
journalism needs to reach the four
corners of the world and if you can't
pay no problem at all however it costs
money and if you can support us then do
and they had tremendous reaction and
they managed to you know break even i
think ahead of where they thought they
were going to
so um
so i think you know that people are
trying to do i mean obviously there's
always you know as in any any
organizations there's obviously kind of
you know there's there's bias and
there's corruption and there's things
that i see happening which you know i
think are
unpleasant in terms of invasion of
privacy and things like that but you
know that's been with us forever and i
probably always will uh always will be
but i think you know yeah i just have i
just have the privilege i guess of being
able to offer a slightly different view
the bastards are ubiquitous it doesn't
matter where you are or what industry
you're in the basketball is going to be
they're going to be everywhere i'm
pretty fascinated thinking about
what it what it does
to the psyche on mass
for people to hear stories
very
vociferous aggressive eye-catching
stories and never get to hear
the conclusion to them never get to tie
up that loose end that's something i've
never ever thought of before but it's
almost unless it's a court case
in which the court case itself becomes
another piece of novelty that people
want to get to the only reason that that
closure is being featured is that the
closure is also another piece of novelty
but for the most part you hear the
afghanistan exit is a perfect example we
all knew what happened
with those photos of people falling from
the plane as it's taking off they're
clinging to it as they're running along
and they're waving at the camera
and i i don't know how that's
even been completed i have no idea at
all
well this is this is this is true and
also i mean i suppose the other thing is
arguably you know you could do a
magazine that does this every six months
uh you could do one that does it every
year you know there's loads of stories
that we could continue to follow up and
you know when when does it end right
when did the ripples stop emerging from
that from that story um and i suppose
that we've always kind of positioned the
magazine is halfway between
a magazine and a history book right you
know it's like it's it's sort of you
know three months
i mean we do do deeper stuff than that
so i mean it's it's um often the um the
stories are kind of inspired by
something that happened in that
three-month period but we'll reach
further back and what i guess what we
try to do
is given that we have these lovely like
long-form stories that we can we can do
is we try to get to do what a lot of
journalists aren't given time to do
which is um provide lots of context and
seek out lots and lots of expert opinion
and um you know like try to try to take
a broad view and that's that's very
difficult to do if you're having to turn
out stories you know but that's the
thing that's such a dream
it's the consistent ambient
unfulfilled open loop
that it has to have an impact on the
public's psychology it has to you're
constantly being fed
issues that do not get resolved that's
what the news is
that's true that's true and also of
course i mean you know this is not a new
thing and this is
this is this is just the nature of news
as we kind of see it um
is that
because everything is you know not
everything because there's a lot of
terribly bleak things out there
um and because
you want to cut through with your
stories
you kind of have to escalate i mean you
know this is this is right yeah this
kind of
feeds back to this amazing um anna lemke
uh you know interview that we're talking
about that you you you kind of you know
you you you can't you just you can't
give people the same thing and expect
the same reaction you kind of have to
escalate so
and that's part of the reason i think
why you know so many people have said
that they want to switch off the news
you know and that they feel so much
better when they stop reading the news
for a few months because they can't do
anything about it you know none of the
massive issues are anything that we can
actually influence we can't influence
government coronavirus policy we can't
influence china's plans to build coal
fired power stations we can't do
anything about any of these things
and yet they weigh on us as though we
could and as though we're like we're not
fulfilling it so you're right news is
very anxiety-inducing which is part of
the reason that um you know that people
want to consume it because they think
that if they can consume it then they
can master it and somehow get on top of
it but they can't i mean i kind of wish
that i could stop reading the news but i
can't because it's my job i got sent a
plugin by my buddy george called tweemx
which is just a plugin for chrome and
it's
it brings up a highlight of the person
whose profile you're on their top tweets
of all time by likes and retweets but
the most important thing that it does is
it covers over the trending
portion
of my twitter home page so i go on to my
news feed now and this thing comes up
and if it if you're not on someone's
profile it just randomly chooses one of
the people that you follow
and right and it brings up their best
tweets of all time which is awesome
because i only follow 99 people so
they're always someone that i know or
some of the apps that you adore what
they're doing but on top of that
it stops me from seeing trending
that that thing on the side and when you
realize when you log on
there is nothing that i can be surprised
by now
that would go
in that point
right
it could be
any story at all i don't know whether
you've seen
um
i can't remember who the comedian is
from america
that did this but they pieced together i
think it might have been ryan long ryan
long pieced together how you make an
eye-catching headline and it's just a
bunch of
uh particular group does something
in this so it's outraged mothers
fighting over
um
misappropriated cat culture or something
like that and it's just that's how you
piece it together and he he does all
that and you look at you look at the
side of trending and you think this is
[ __ ] this is the world that we're in
this sort of formulaic algorithmic
headline yeah definitely if you can get
if you can get some outrage in there
that's amazing because then you get
multiple bites of the cherry right so
you can scrape together if if you look
on twitter you can find three or four
people who are outraged about anything
right anything like you know vanilla ice
cream you know people smiling too much
whatever it might be they can find them
outrage at this vanilla you know vanilla
ice cream outrage and then you get that
and then you get the reaction against
that and then you can report that i mean
you can go on with this forever people
people kind of do but i mean that's
funny about the kind of kind of gaming
the system because you know it you know
at the beginning it used to be stuff
like
writing you know uh
writing the word sex in white on white
background a thousand times over so
people you know then obviously that was
way too sophisticated way too
unsophisticated and then they've got
content and then you know putting the
names of
celebrities
into your into your titles you'd have
these incredibly dry
publications that for some reason were
referencing britney spears and nobody
really kind of you know why are you
doing that you're a plumbing magazine
you know but but you know it kind of all
feeds into all health and this is just
the latest part of that right yeah you
just kind of concoct what will work what
will cut through um but the problem is
because we've all been doing it for so
long the kind of the
the sort of the sheer outrage you need
to cut through if if you're if you're
going for the outrage angle is difficult
but that said you know i mentioned
before you know this this pendulum it
does swing back and people kind of get
sick of it i mean you know when we when
we launched
people were so in love with digital
people were prepared to without any sort
of credible business model they were
prepared long-standing publishers would
say yeah i mean think you know like
we're digital first now how are you
going to make money i don't know it'll
become apparent what are you talking
about
are you talking about those and also you
know how in love people were with their
smartphones i mean you know there was
nothing wrong with smartphones and now
everybody's uneasy about their
smartphones everybody's trying to detox
trying to kind of get themselves wean
themselves off it they're anxious about
their kids having it they know
you know how much time they're spending
just scrolling through you know
stuff that they don't need to scroll
through on social so i think i think
these things change and you know and
actually so our maxine's a case in point
you know we've we've managed to build
like a modest subscriber base um that uh
funds us to do good journalism using
antiquated communication medium
that's true yeah exactly yeah go proper
old school but i think almost you need
to do that right so you need to do
the opposite of what other people doing
so you do print instead of digital you
do read a funded instead of invasive
personalized advertising and you do slow
instead of fast and then you can it's
always going to be a niche but you might
have a niece that works i think that
you're right about the counter culture
thing and i think that we are at the
beginning of that pendulum starting to
move that you see
how much support people's sub stacks and
patreons get
um
what do you think
let's say it's 20 years or 30 let's say
it's 50 years time
what do you think that the world will
look back on this period
of limbic hijack and
technology that is incredibly unethical
manipulating the most base elements of
our psychology to get us to stay on site
for this long what do you think people
are going to look back on this
period of history and
consider
wow
that's quite a big question i'm aware
i'm asking you to be the most sort of
divinated
clairvoyant that you can but just well
no it's funny so i see i did this um i
did this tedx in 2014 and one of the
things that i said i sort of i wanted
some nice bold statements for the end
and i said in 10 years time there won't
be a single printed like a single major
printed newspaper left uh in um in the
in western europe or something like that
and so i'm slightly anxious now because
it's i got like two years to go
there's lots of them come on guys tick
tock tick tock just go out of business i
mean a lot have folded but still um well
it's funny isn't it when
when you look back obviously what
happens is that all the noise kind of
all the noise kind of goes away uh you
know you look back on entire decades
like the the kind of 70s what was it the
decade off well like you can name kind
of three or four things and one of them
is disco so you know i mean all the
people who lived through that is
absolutely nonsensical
but i would imagine that um
a huge amount of it will be to do with
climate stuff won't it so it will be
these guys were such morons why didn't
they just do
you know why didn't they just do cold
fusion like we've got and sort it out
limitless power what on earth we're
thinking that's so stupid
um or can you imagine them living in a
time before they knew that there were
aliens or something like that it'll be
some massive thing that we've not you
know um
i think in terms of of
my my strong feeling is that
in terms of the the way that you know
big social media organizations have been
operating and big tech companies have
been operating i think that that won't
persist because i think people won't
stand for it people are getting way too
savvy about it as a very basic thing
people are going to demand to have the
value of their information i think
you know and all of the technology
exists to put that in place right people
could be micro you know compensated for
all of the data that is sold behind the
scenes about them and they could also be
compensated every time that there's a
data breach you know every time that
people don't haven't kind of protected
them whatever it might be so i imagine
that that sort of thing might that might
mark a shift but in terms of kind of
broader news media i guess probably
it'll still you know it'll still be
guided by the same things that we want
as humans which is
we want to amass enough information that
will be invulnerable and we'll have a
special advantage over all the other
humans that will be protected and our
families will be protected uh which is
obviously you know nonsense
absolutely impossible do you have a side
interest in data science or something
because you've written a
book that works out things like how much
it would cost to buy everything in an
edition of vogue or what the actual best
inventions since sliced bread have been
or the uk's most popular dog breeds are
you a closet data scientist too
um so i would never glorify myself as a
data scientist but since we launched the
magazine so in the first issue the
magazine my co-editor marcus said do you
know what we should do we should do some
infographics infographics are fun and
our art director who's the best artist
our director in the world sort of came
onto this and said yeah so from the very
first issue we started doing
infographics and just trying to work out
you know how we do them and over years
we've we've kind of worked out well
we've got we've got better better than i
think and um and so actually what
happened with this book was it was april
2020
and uh the first lockdown
and suddenly we'd gone from selling you
know three or four thousand copies of
the magazine at the newsstand to selling
zero copies because nobody was going to
you know airports nobody was going to
book shops nobody was going to train
stations i mean obviously as you know in
terms of what was going on at the time
that was a very small drama but for our
our business that was a big deal
and so uh we were just casting around
for something that we could we could do
a project that we could all throw
ourselves into in this time when we were
you know not going out when we were
staying at home and we thought let's do
a book because we talked about doing a
book for ages and we had 10 years worth
of infographics so we started putting
stuff together and coming up with new
ideas and how it would all look and then
we found an agent and um we got the we
got an offer from bloomsby so we sold it
to them and then we started putting
together and i love infographics
and i'm not a data scientist but i have
enough i have enough data manipulation
skills to pull together you know um
infographics and to do research for them
and they're brilliant for a magazine
because they give you
they give you a way in i think that they
are like a gateway drug
for magazine purchases and i've seen
people at the newsstand flicking through
a copy of delay gratification
you know and it's not the long-form
features the earnest kind of analysis
any of that that they stop at it's the
funnies it's the little infographics the
little things like oh wow oh that my
goodness did you know how many chickens
there are wow and um so that's
that's you know been great for us for
the magazine but i also think that
they're they're really interesting from
a journalistic point of view because
you can kind of use them in a way
slightly to take the heat out of of you
know kind of quite controversial stories
because you could just you know you can
just put the facts down right and you
can you can kind of give people a way
into the facts you know that kind of
looks good and that kind of amuses them
and intrigues them at the same time as
as hopefully giving them some some
information so they're great and this
yeah this book is i mean this book is 10
years in the making and he's got lots
and lots of lovely silly stuff in there
but it's got quite a lot of serious
stuff in it i think i'm glad that you
mentioned what's the best thing since
sliced bread because that took me
flipping forever to work out how to
answer that question um but uh but
basically what we ended up doing was
getting loads and loads of lists the
eminent bodies had produced the best
human inventions of all time
and then we we taught it up we did a
metalist so we totted up all of that
kind of votes we worked out what the
most kind of most lawded inventions in
human history
were post the industrial revolution so
it wasn't like fire and the wheel and
stuff like that and then we found out
when sliced bread was invented it was
introduced in 1928 i think in june 1928
and then we just looked at the two
inventions that were best ranked after
that which were spoiler alert they were
penicillin and the internet and
penicillin only just scraped under the
wire because i think that was something
like september 1928 but that's it you
know what that wasn't
grown on bread as well
yeah so that's too bread based and if
we've been able to make the internet off
of bread
we would have had three bread-based
inventions
yeah that's true yeah well i mean you
know let's not rule it out at this stage
let's see if we get some some funding
into bread yeah so
i've i've got some of my favorite ones
that i went through so the world's
oldest person was 122 years old and she
was french
apparently yeah jean-claude yeah yeah
and um so we like looking at old people
so we did this whole infographic at the
uh the other end of the book
which was um it was called how to live
forever um but it had a little asterisk
that said up to a maximum of 122 years
and what we did was we looked at super
centenarians so people who had lived
older than 110
and the nice thing about that is that
they've all been interviewed at some
stage and i mean quite often they're you
know so barely kind of capable of giving
answers but the one question everybody
has always asked them is how did you
live to such an old age
and um
and the answers are just just absolutely
delightful so um
there's mad stuff like uh
so whiskey and boiled onions uh eating
boiled polenta a sense of humor quite a
few people said that lifelong virginity
eugenie blanchard lifelong virginity god
no alcohol tobacco or
or fooling around
no fooling around no feelings around
my favorite one is there's a lady who
said um
daily raw steak and brandy and leaving
her husband aged 39.
um so that's quite nice like you can you
can start to get i mean i'm not sure i
wouldn't necessarily i'm not necessarily
endorsing
lifelong virginity in a all brandy diet
to people but there's there's kind of
nice funny things that you can find out
for me i'm a big fan of may harrington
who lived to 113 died on the 29th of
december 2002
and just has nothing divulged written
below her advice yeah she's not giving
her secrets away
what would she yeah enjoy dying at 80
[ __ ]
yeah exactly i knew i didn't tell you
didn't know and then uh the oldest
living creature was a clam that lived to
507 years old until he was accidentally
killed by researchers
that's right i think it was the the
researchers who found the clam
accidentally in the process of
identifying the clam working out how old
it was accidentally killed it so i mean
it could have been you know like it
could have gone a lot you know
didn't have a good innings that's
unbelievable the oldest cow 48 years
the oldest goat 22 years 29 years for
the oldest dog that's i mean there's a
43 year old spider in here as well which
i do not want to meet
no exactly exactly and with all of these
things as well
you know
what one thing that we found out uh in
making this book you know and going
through these billions and billions of
of of kind of data sources and some are
actually kind of fantastic and you know
um
and you know many many diligent people
kind of compiling them so on is that you
also you also do get to a few where you
think
how did you know that like did something
you know like the spider one was it just
was it just kept in one place for those
40 whatever years it was i mean
potentially maybe it was maybe it was in
the zoo or whatever
but if not you know is there just the
chance that a younger spider scuttled in
at some point just like you've got
you've got some concerns around the
veracity of the conclusions of the
spider research
you can't just put its leg off and look
at how many rings are inside of it
that's not the way it works that's big
you can't carpenter spider yeah um uh
and i think you know there's i think
there's just a lot of
in terms of kind of the data that's out
there necessarily
you know there's a lot of um best
guesses and kind of approximations i
mean actually if you think about
something like uh
like co2 emissions or whatever
you know we've got these things and
broadly they're probably you know like
ballpark correct but then also like no
government in the world even the most
scrupulous and well-funded government is
measuring every single you know fire in
somebody's back garden or every single
kind of you know whatever it might be
and certainly that's you know that's
even the best funded ones and a lot of
people it'll be i think probably just a
finger in the air like approximating it
yeah looking at the co2 emissions i was
quite interested in this the uk has seen
the biggest co2 emissions drop of all
g20 nations a decrease of 41
since 1990 meanwhile china is emitting
11.5
billion tons of co2 per year which
accounts for 30.3 percent of the global
total that's one country
contributing 30.3 percent of the entire
global total of co2 emissions
it's true i mean
one thing to kind of bear in mind i
suppose about that you know that's that
is an impressive drop by the uk and um a
lot of it has been this real kind of
like throwing ourselves into renewables
and so actually since 1990 you know
coal-fired um power energy production
has has kind of absolutely plummeted but
another thing that's happened is that
manufacturing in this country has
effectively been offshored to china
so you know our emissions data doesn't
take into account the embedded emissions
of the products that we buy constantly
from china
you know made there using less clean
energy and that are shipped here
flown here whatever it might be you know
so actually there's there's loads of
different ways of i mean even in this
you know so actually there's there's
three different
kind of
major standards for how you measure
emissions and some of them take into
account uh you know like uh aviation and
then
yeah you know all of these different
things so um so yeah i mean generally
the uk has done well um it's it's
probably also the case that a lot of the
low-hanging fruit for the uk
has now been been picked um was actually
you know somewhere somewhere like china
actually um they they haven't kind of
you know made that switch to renewables
but if they did that would make a
massive difference i'm terrified of
china sometimes i just sit and think
about what it's going to be like with
our new
east asian overlords which personally i
welcome with open arms and have always
been an ardent supporter of the xi
jinping
entire everything that he's done his
hair his outfits
yeah
his thirty point three percent of the
global total co2 emissions per year i i
welcome them
absolutely absolutely well so
we did actually we did an interesting
infographic in the book about that and
it was just called um how has china
changed and we just looked at some of
the data um about
what has happened to kind of you know
the the quality of life of uh citizens
in china
in the 20 years you know the last 20
years
and it is astonishing you know across so
many different measures across you know
um education um public health uh you
know earnings
just you know all of these different
things chinese citizens have leapt ahead
their government has brought them
incredible incredible benefits
and but i mean you were absolutely right
that they are on the path to becoming
our overlords i mean certainly
economically one of the kind of the most
telling things as well um in the book
for me was we just looked at how um
gdp
um has changed in the in the kind of the
the nations of the world with the
highest gdp and it's fascinating because
japan's gdp has increased by something
like three percent
um in that in that last 20 years and
china's has increased by more than a
thousand percent i mean it is completely
i think the uk is around 97 or something
like that but it's just i mean it's it's
an incredible thing that's been
happening there in the background this
economic
you know expansion
um which has been coupled with a lot of
um kind of very good things for some of
the citizens and a lot of very bad
things for some of the other
totalitarian communist regime is good
for the gdp that's effective that's the
la it's effective effective gets the job
done
i would love to see a
an accurately done study around
happiness levels and around fulfillment
and meaning levels for chinese citizens
you're never going to the same as
finding out if kovit came from
wuhan lab or whatever we're never going
to find out i think it's very unlikely
that we're going to find out because you
by its very nature the people that would
be conducting the study have a perverse
incentive around the outcomes of the
study
but
i don't know what it's like to be a
chinese citizen with a social credit
score and all of your movements being
tracked and have you seen that they've
got gate analysis now on the artificial
intelligence system so even if you don't
show your face
they can predict who you are to a 97
accuracy simply by the way that you walk
i was petrifying terrific petrifying
yeah i mean you also have you know uh
what's going on in xinjiang and with the
uyghurs you know this is a kind of a
a
petrifying development i mean the other
thing to to kind of add in i suppose
about the you know there's this
incredible expansion economic expansion
is of course you have to measure from
the base so actually you know japan 20
years ago was was one of the kind of the
most developed nations in the world and
china has made this drastic jump finally
brought up with everybody else exactly
and of course i mean it's it's
the most popular nation on on the planet
as well so actually the interesting
thing as well is the gdp is is colossal
the gdp per capita uh for china is still
very middling you know there's a lot of
there's a lot of people not doing kind
of particularly well and there's lots of
people who are doing very well um but
yeah i mean you know you could do you
could do a book of infographics just on
china i mean just on on what's happening
the mad stuff you know the we looked at
the tallest towers in the world i think
at least seven of them are in china you
know the tallest skyscrapers in the
world so it's completely kind of
eclipsed
what's the new one because there's a new
one is it in
some saudi place that's going to oh
there's a jedi tower it's going to wipe
the floor with the burj al-arab
right that's right
that's right so burj khalifa is your
tallest you've got one two three four
five six of the top taller um top ten
tallest towers uh um in china at the
moment and then i think it's the jeddah
tower which is scheduled to open in 2024
which is going to be notionally a
kilometer high
and that should be was that saudi arabia
that's in jeddah in saudi arabia yeah
and then i know from my trip to dubai
last winter that they are building in
the center of a brand new marina that's
going to be downtown huge downtown
marina they are building just it's not a
building it's just a spike in the ground
but this spike in the ground is going to
be 1.1 kilometers high
so they're already planning to take the
title that they're about to lose
to jeddah
back
and put it in the same place it's just i
i [ __ ] you not i [ __ ] you know it's a
spike in the ground
it does all feel a little bit a little
bit sort of old-fashioned this doesn't
it you know like it's sort of showing
off competition with towers i mean we've
got a little bit of it actually it's
quite interesting with the um the kind
of the recent launches kind of bezos and
and branson and so on doing these these
big launches into space and a lot of
people just saying
why are you doing that you don't think
what you've got to do when you've got
basically unlimited unlimited oil money
in the middle east what have you got to
do other than stick the biggest spike in
the world in the ground that's it that's
all that's left
yeah i mean i suppose so i mean that's
kind of that's slightly the the bezel's
argument although bezos is also saying
that you know we're going to learn loads
of stuff from him going into space
um
but i don't know it just seems it feels
a bit of an old-fashioned way to spend
your spending billions doesn't it do you
see what elon tweeted recently talking
about how people were criticizing him
for not paying tax on his unrealized
gains from stockholdings so
he did a twitter poll to say should i
just dump 10 of tesla stock uh and
i'll abide by whatever the results of
this poll are and
that ended up with
a twitter poll deciding the fate of 20
billion dollars
worth of stocks and they decided on yes
it ended up at 57 and a bit percent said
yes so it sounds like if you're holding
tesla stock might be an idea to
just
let it get out of the market for the
time being and then re-buy back in
because elon's about to dump a little
bit
oh god save us but i mean it all it
keeps it keeps us in interesting stories
right you know right it gives you
something to talk about uh dog breeds i
love this one i hear i love dogs the
most popular dog crossbreed was
cockapoos with 39 000 being sold through
pets for homes in 2020 this is in the uk
10 of the 24 most popular dog breeds has
poodles as parents and cava poos are the
most expensive dogs now i know a lot of
people that have got cockapoos so i
anecdotally can completely back this
yeah well this was fascinating so this
was something that we looked at in the
magazine first right because it was a
big phenomenon about kovid and the
lockdown so actually we we did a
ton a ton a ton of um
infographics about covid i mean there
was so much amazing data there to to
play with and this was a fascinating
peripheral one it was it was going
through this unbelievable inflation
um so there's two things going on so
people getting more and more interested
in interested in crossbreeds um and they
were also paying more and more and more
for them
and so we got this incredible data quite
often you know for uh for the book we
would kind of go and approach somebody
we thought had some interesting data and
pets for homes did have interesting days
they sell kind of tons and tons of dogs
i think the thing one of the things that
i like the most though i'm not
particularly dog person but i do love um
the kind of these uh portmanteau names
so you've got um
yo you've got cavapoo and malty poo and
golden doodle but you've got pomsky
puchon you've got sprutal
you've got sprocker a mulchy a morkie a
pomchi a chalky a puggle a jug and a
sharkie i just kind of lovely lovely
things but the prices for these things
were insane i mean actually the thing to
really invested in the last year has
been
crossbreed dogs dogs
yeah crazy i'm trying to work out what
it is about poodles
that make them because i know that
cockapoos are i want to say
hypoallergenic which sounds like the
sort of thing that you look for in a bed
pillow oh yeah well thankfully because
jonathan he's got infotainment so we
need to have a hypoallergenic [ __ ]
pillowcase for him else he comes out
with a rash
like but yeah i think that there's
something
that's exactly right but it's the
poodles that are hypoallergenic okay so
they pass that down that's a dominant
gene is it like having brown eyes the
hypoallergenic nature is that gets
passed down even if you make that with a
dulux dog the dulux dog's jeans just get
completely whitewashed by the poodle
now that you have me there i think
that's the case but you know what i
don't want to definitively say that but
um but can i tell you about so the the
other so i'm really glad that you picked
that one up the other one that i loved
from the the lockdown
was and the other kind of really novel
bit of data that we got was we um we
looked at what people were searching for
across the world during lockdown
and it was kind of it was it was so
revelatory because it's such a such a
weird experience we've all had right we
all went through this and you know a
third of the world at one point was in
some form of lockdown
and we did quite earnest stuff about the
disease and how it spread
um and you know the financial impact and
so on but the really human story and i
think that's where the infographics work
best is when they kind of got this real
human story at the heart of it was what
people were searching for on google
and um we so we went to google and we
said look the sort of thing that we're
looking for is um is
you know kind of data that tells us
about you know how people's priorities
changed so the data that we got was
um searches that had increased the most
year on year so the year before the the
pandemic and then the year after and
then we drilled down we got it kind of
day by day so we related it to how the
whole thing unfolded so fascinatingly
before
um the quran virus was declared a
pandemic the big thing that people were
searching for was hoarding you know you
know we can all remember there was this
unease and you know there were things
starting to kind of people were starting
to hoard things we weren't quite sure
what's going on and then in order
this isn't all of them but when hoarding
toilet paper coronavirus people just
across the world in every language under
the sun just going what is coronavirus
hydroxychloroquine when trump was just
like this is you know this i'm
interested in this this is going to sort
things out
ammunition
so driven by people in the states being
like right it's the end of the world
let's load up exercise bike my absolute
favorite bit is on day 12 there's two
searches that spike the first one is
homeschooling so people just be like how
the hell do i do this and the second one
is when will schools open
then you had social distancing which is
a term that had not had never been
searched for in a quantity that it would
register on google's radar before
complete breakout term same with uh zoom
dating cut your own hair permit to go
outside this is lovely cafe sounds on
youtube people hadn't searched for that
before sounds like they wanted to sound
make themselves feel like they were in a
cafe while they were saturday like
they're in a cafe so you know what they
used to do in the old days was go to a
cafe
and then there was just sitting at home
on their bed and be like god this is a
bit so [ __ ] silent in here let me get
let me get the sound of sheila making a
cup of tea so which you know was the
market provided like the clink and the
clank and they're sort of you know
people tamping down espressos or
whatever unmute on zoom
how to make your phone not the most
boomer search ever
why is my face not here yeah um where
are my grandchildren yeah how to make
mcdonald's and then you know all of this
kind of stuff all this this kind of
stuff you know like mads kind of social
stuff and then another breakout thing
and this was
quite a long way down the line but how
many people can attend a funeral this
was a breakout search that people hadn't
had to think about before because well
as many people as can fit in the church
or crematorium but that was the thing
that people were searching for on maps
around the world so i love i love that
sort of data you know where it's it's
kind of it's both epic because it's on a
global scale but it's also personal and
immediately yeah relatable you
understand it are you familiar with seth
stevens davidowitz yes yes everybody
lies yeah so seth's been on the show and
he's that guy's a beast of with his data
and i saw a feature that he did
he was able to predict him or his office
were able to predict
the rates of covert infections
three to five days ahead
of the cdc
based on aggregated google data based on
people searching for loss of taste high
temperature loss of smell
wow
and if you map
loss of taste high temperature loss of
smell and a couple of other searches
that were common if you map those on the
graph you see that they're just a lead
measure for the lagging measure that
ends up being covert cases
yeah yeah yeah yeah well is there not
this idea also that you know
you could absolutely use people's kind
of search history you could you could
have kind of algorithms kind of
constantly scanning and if people opted
into it into their search histories and
just kind of patching together firstly
outbreaks of kind of various different
infectious diseases but also um
you know you could correlate it with
other information that you have about
them and say you know what actually
something could pop up and say yo you
should go to your doctor and get this
checked out you know you have searched
for this particular bowel issue several
times and it's probably okay but you
know like you know that you could just
get so much more joined up about all of
this particularly if you also had of
course you know if you were linked into
their kind of their blood pressure and
you know all the things that are going
through on their wrists and so on but
thinking in a techno-utopian
way it's a bit of a shame that the
period of the world that we're living in
at the moment everybody is incredibly
protective about their data because we
do not believe that the people who are
mining our data have our best interests
at heart you can imagine another world
in which
we
the mark zuckerbergs and the jeff bezos
of the world were just seen as these
benevolent saints right these sort of
technocracy saints that were just all
that they did was make our lives better
and we knew that they had our best
interests at heart and they weren't
selling it and they weren't trying to
olympically hijack us and we just wanted
more we wanted to just continue to give
ourselves away
but
because of the framing that this
situation has been given because of
concerns around privacy and huma i had
sebastian younger on the show not long
ago talking about the brutal history of
freedom and freedom is something that we
have been fighting for for a very very
long time
so when you start to encroach on that
humans have a very visceral response
they're really really not happy about it
and
understandably so
but there could have been this could
have been done a different way and we
may end up in a place where it is done
in a different way but the amount of
time it's going to need
to regain the public's trust of being
think about big tech the words big tech
it makes you think of this dark
malevolent being you know hiding at the
top of some [ __ ] gilded tower behind
an astroturf lawn like that's that you
know it's silicon valley run amok and
that's what we think about we think
they're selling our data they're trying
to target us with ads i don't want them
to even know my [ __ ] name let alone
my blood pressure that's what that's how
we feel
about this situation but it could have
been different and
it would have been nice it would have
been nice to have wanted to
supply as much data that you have to
these companies as possible maybe i have
no idea about this but maybe web 3
will be able to enable this a little bit
more because you can have genuine levels
of security
and
i i don't understand how it works but
someone said that it sounds like it
might be a better version than the
internet we have at the moment
well i mean it would be difficult would
it but i mean you're absolutely right
there was there was very much missed
opportunity there because actually when
all of these things started we could
only see the benefits right i mean you
know some people were moaning because
actually it turned out that all of the
people that they looked up on facebook
from their childhood you know there was
a reason that they weren't in touch with
them anymore and they're all pricks
that i wasn't friends with yeah exactly
exactly exactly so there were things
like that but generally there was a lot
of wow and i get this for free wow and
you know there were incredible social
benefits and people kind of reconnecting
and there were wonderful wonderful
things and you're absolutely right there
must have been a moment at which you
built enough but the problem is you only
build enough mass by making it free
um because there can't be that barrier
to entry but once you set up that
relationship where you know the people
you know we are not the clients with the
products it's very difficult to turn
that round and at some point you say
tell me what do you want do you want
this but you pay for it and we won't
mess around with your data or well i
mean you can't there's no way you can
package that up you have to continue
once you've set this course it has to be
all about freedom
but i don't know i think you know the
the wiser that people get about what is
happening and what it's i mean
less so about the data but what it's
doing to to your mental health i think
to be kind of to leave yourself this
open to constant constant distraction
and constant kind of titillation and
constant anxiety and so on the more
people move away from that and the more
people you know capitalism moves in and
it provides alternatives not necessarily
quarterly printed magazines um but like
other stuff other tech stuff you know
where there's a kind of a kudos
associated and you know you pay for it
but but you get a better service that's
the visceral
response the fact that everybody
understands that their relationship i
don't know a single person whose
relationship with technology doesn't
need work
and
10 years ago that would have almost not
been the case
i don't know a single person that
doesn't need to work on the relationship
with technology and the fact that that's
there and it's so obvious and it's felt
it's a felt sense by everyone that's the
gateway drug to people saying we need to
have a system-wide change with how
technology and us relate you might see
something when we move more towards ar
and vr and wearables being a little bit
more integrated
when you get a step change in the type
of um
media mechanism or the type of
consumption mechanism you may be able to
reset some of the markets expectations
to do with cost to do with relationship
between you and the supplier or the
the tech company so that may be that may
be something but again it's just
anchoring bias it's the fact that until
you change a bunch of different things
at once we fix ourselves to well this
was free and so many people want to have
all of the things that they think that
they want with none of the things that
they know that they don't want so i want
to still have be able to access my
friends and talk to them but i don't
want them to limbically hijack me but i
also don't want to pay for it it's like
you don't get to have those three things
exactly the reason it's free is because
they're selling your data and they're
targeting you with ads so another one
another one of the things that you
looked at which was the decade with the
most blockbusters based on an original
idea
oh yes that was the 1980s it was the 80s
unsurprisingly
the 2010s came last last last out of the
last 100 years
the last century
the worst
decade
for blockbusters based on an original
idea was the 2010s
isn't that fascinating yeah i mean it's
all it's all kind of based on well it's
either it's kind of remakes and it's
based on story story books and things
like that and um
yeah i mean there was so actually if you
look at it the 80s you had so the
biggest
you know biggest film of each year um in
terms of ticket sales you had star wars
uh episode five the empire strikes back
so you got first i was um uh um sorry
the first time you got 1980 you got star
wars and then you've got 81 you've got
braids of the lost ark 82 you've got e.t
83 you've got another star wars 84
you've got indiana jones uh back to the
future top guys spielberg's attraction
isn't he i mean you know indiana jones
who said all just kind of just original
ideas not based on anything
um so yeah that's uh yeah the
that stuff is absolutely lovely i think
one of the the nicest things that we've
done in film is um i was going to come
back to it is how to win an oscar
so we just looked at every single oscar
winner going back to 1928 every single
male and female winner of the best actor
category um and it's fascinating because
we look to kind of like modally
how you're most likely to win uh because
everybody's got that question when it
comes around to um oscar season like you
know who's going to win and they've all
got your pet theories and actually it's
fascinating to see the facts which is
that
modally speaking you'll play a fictional
character
who's north american from the present
day if you're a man from the recent past
if you're a woman who works as a soldier
a lawman a monarch a politician a
creative media type or a performer if
you're a man
and how depressing is this who works as
a performer a housewife a mother a
socialite a service industry type or a
prostitute escort if you're in that
order
who participates in no sexual scenes and
who in the end doesn't die on screen and
these are these are quite these are very
clear trends as well like you know it's
it's fictional character and it is north
american now none of that is necessarily
particularly surprising but i think one
of the nice things about diving into
data sets like this is it kind of allows
you to confirm you know or confound the
prejudices and the ideas that you that
you already have about you know what you
would expect to see going into this
story but i love that one in the film a
lot of cultural stuff is really nice um
we did a lovely one about and we got
this data from spotify about
songs that have stood the test of time
so the songs from each year going back
to the 50s
um that are the most played now
so you know like uh uh i think like um
yeah and it's quite funny because
actually it's almost like a it's like a
list of guilty pleasures it's a bit like
you know uh cess book everybody lies you
know you tell the truth to spotify
because you actually want to listen to
those songs and you might you know if
you were asked to compose your list of
the best songs of the last 50 years
whatever none of those are going to
feature
one of my buddies one of my buddies is
absolutely adamant that the window into
a person's soul is their suggested
videos on youtube home that what someone
watches between 10 p.m and 11 p.m at
night on a weekday evening on youtube
that's that's who they really are not
the person that they tell you not who
they are with their with their lover in
their most vulnerable moments it's the
[ __ ] that they watch between 10 p.m and
11 p.m at night on youtube
yeah i could see that and that book
everybody lies there was a lot of stuff
in that wasn't it because it has he has
this lovely example um which is you know
what people write about their partner on
facebook as opposed to what they type
into google
um about their partner it's mad like you
know my boyfriend is so sweet charming
kind generous like you know adorable
whatever it is and then people are
typing into google
my boyfriend is horrible my boyfriend is
my boyfriend autistic what's wrong with
my boyfriend why is my boyfriend so mean
and that's how we use google it's like
it's you know like it's a electronic
psycho psychiatrist on the couch isn't
it why is this happening i mean one of
the things i liked in the um in the the
thing um the pandemic searches one of
the things people were just doing in
large enough numbers for it to register
a massive spike was just going into
google and typing in i'm bored
and that's amazing would you would you
[ __ ] want them to do it as a search
engine but i mean it's actually you know
it probably would throw up some useful
stuff
but i love that just people you know all
around the world in all different
languages i'm bored
569 people have been to space 24 went to
the moon 12 of which walked on the moon
and three went to the moon twice
plus we left two golf balls on the moon
because one of the astronauts played
golf up there
that's right yeah so actually pulling
together that data was um was quite a
colossal job because it's not
centralized so i'm not sure that
anybody's ever calculated that before
there are kind of various different
calculations floating about the place
but we we got the kind of the data from
nasa and from the russian space agency
from the chinese space agency um and
from the kind of the private companies
and so yeah so we we we kind of went
through methodically and we've listed
them all i mean i think this is one of
the nice things about this an answer for
everything it's just
there's this kind of
there's this there's this thing where
you quite want to own knowledge right i
mean you're never going to sit there and
read through the list of every single
person who was a scented space in 1984
but i like having it in a book that i
own it's just nice i like it like it's
completism that's what it is it's any
time that you could be completeist about
something every single person they're
immortalized and inherently satisfying
it is satisfying and you know like why
not why not spend eight pages going
through and like calling out the most
exciting things that they've done and
then yeah i mean there's loads of lovely
we had nasa i mean there's so many data
sources that you know obviously we can
do without them nasa's got these amazing
data sources about stuff that we left on
the moon
so there's hammocks
um for you know because the the the
astronauts kind of went up and they
didn't really cater for where they were
going to sleep when they first sent them
so they were kind of effectively sort of
sleeping all hunched up in the
spacecraft and eventually they they
graduated to hammocks and they chucked
them out afterwards um there's quite a
lot of excrement up there there's you
know there's um unused tick bags there's
this amazing thing where there's a stack
of
of stack of money and it's a special i
think it's two dollar bills or something
like here and somebody thought that they
would take it up there and then they
could go back down and then hand them
out souvenirs you know because this is a
this is a special bill and it's been on
the moon wow you know that's that's
amazing but at some point they
jettisoned it like they thought it was a
bad idea or they like they took off and
they're like have i forgotten something
oh [ __ ]
that left 42 42 down on the moon
exactly that was my ticket to the big
time so i mean that's the other thing is
you find out how weird
the world is there's a lot of long tail
stuff as well i don't if you saw we did
one about um government e-petitions
so the uk government has set up and set
up
a few years ago an e-petitions portal
and you can go on there and you can
suggest a new petition and if you get
enough
um
if you get enough votes
on your e-petition i think it's hundred
thousand something ten thousand is that
it will be noticed by someone hundred
thousand is that it gets brought up in
the house of lords i wanna say
it's something like it is is it like it
gets considered for debate in parliament
yes that's it
and certain number of them have been you
know have kind of broken through a tiny
percentage the vast majority of them and
i went through and found out you know i
went through every single year how many
were um submitted how many were kind of
like rejected the vast majority of them
rejected um and there's this lovely
government line that they put underneath
and so it says like e-petition rejected
reason for rejection and usually the
line is just really polite and it just
says
this e-petition does not relate to
something that the government is
responsible for and it's like no [ __ ] so
like some of my favorite ones on there
there's this brilliant one which is um
change the plural of sheep to sheeps
make gingerism part of the
discrimination laws and my absolute
favorite one there's somebody went on
there started deep edition which was
increased the standard size of a wine
bottle to one liter and they had this
lovely little write-up under it and it
just said basically
you know you finish a wine bottle and
you always want just one more glass so
why not make wine bottles a liter and
then you you don't have to open a second
bottle i mean it's brilliant and then
the government rejected it they're like
yeah it's not really that's our remit
mate this is a this is a you problem
yeah
we're more nhs and stuff [ __ ] man yeah
the um the number of times that i've
seen a spurious e-petition go up but it
does seem like
i don't know
that system for americans this i don't
know if there's an equivalent for
americans but
that system is a
it's an a rage outlet for a lot of
people's social justice concerns but the
problem is that
people believe the people that are
voting on it believe that they're
genuinely making a change by doing that
thing
that's the way that i'm going to
contribute to this particular movement
so for instance there's been a
a recent social
concern around spiking in nightclubs not
sure if you've seen right yeah huge huge
concern around it and i run nightclubs
in the uk so it means that i've been
we've been dealing with this on the
front lines as it were and
the main thing that people were pushing
toward there was
we're going to do an e-petition we're
going to get to be considered for debate
in whatever wherever parliament and
one
way that you could look at that
e-petition page
is that
it has it's a simulacrum of doing work
whilst not
requiring any of the things that might
actually enact change
that it
gives people who are indignant and want
to contribute to a social movement it
gives them an outlet that dissipates
their rage
but doesn't
by the numbers seem to actually make
change all that often
that's right i mean i think you do get
certain breakthrough ones and when
you're going through them
there are certain bees in bonnets that
are just you know it's like everybody's
putting up thing over and over and over
and over again but you're right there's
a certain amount of virtue signaling
going on um you know you share any
petition on your socials and that's kind
of like you've done something about it
but you haven't actually done anything
about it there was this amazing
statistic and i can't remember exactly
what it was but there's this
frighteningly high percentage
of news stories
where um they are shared um online
before people have read the story at all
so you've been watching twitter if you
do that now
do you if you retweet an article
if you retweet an article without
twitter without opening the link and
twitter knows if you've opened the link
yeah twitter pops up and says
you haven't read this do you want to
read the article before retweeting
that's amazing because somebody did an
amazing spoof on it where they put in
some quite
uh
powerful headline which was kind of
virtually signaling headline and then um
there was i think there was a paragraph
of real text and then underneath it the
text basically said
you're a bunch of idiots uh and if
you've read this far then kind of
congratulations but this is all nonsense
that kind of made up and people were
just sharing it kind of willy-nilly oh
yeah this is this is important work you
got to read this you know i mean our
whole our whole digital system is kind
of geared up for that i don't know
though i don't know
whether
you're right at some level it's just
kind of a pressure valve and it's a way
of making people feel that they've done
good but also i suppose i kind of
applaud
any government that's prepared to wade
through i mean there's something quite
nice about that some official going
through and being like the [ __ ] guy
in that department can you imagine
can you imagine that poor bastard's job
no we're not going to make ginger isn't
part of the discrimination laws no we're
not going to give you extra large
bottles of wine just buy i don't know
buy a third size bottle of wine it's not
to do with us
i want to serve what is what have i
missed off what was one of your
favorites from the book that we haven't
covered
good question so there's uh there's all
sorts of lovely things i think um
there's a very simple one that i really
like which is just called uh where the
babies come from and i'm really
interested in this um which is uh that
it's just about fertility rates around
the world and i've read this really
really good um book a few years ago
empty planet
um
i interviewed the one of the authors
there's two authors i think i
interviewed john ebberson and um it's
basically saying that if you look at the
fertility rates as in the number of
babies that women around the world are
having
in many many countries
they are way below replacement rate so
in a modern economy
where you've got a good chance of your
kids very good chance of your kids
surviving through childhood
um
you need to be having something like 2.1
kids per woman in the population in
order to maintain your population static
without any immigration
and in
dozens and dozens of countries around
the world that is not the case and in
many it's nowhere near the case and the
trend is all downwards
and
a lot of that is a good thing because a
lot of that is people moving from
primarily agricultural societies to more
urbanized societies it's women becoming
educated and realizing they've got more
options it's people leaving it later to
have kids and it's birth control there's
all sorts of wonderful things
but you know their argument in this book
which we did kind of a big feature on
was that what's going to happen is we're
going to reach a tipping point with the
global population much earlier than the
un is predicting um and after that it's
only going to go one direction the
global population of humans will shrink
year on year and year on year and year
and nothing is going to change it
because the economics of it kind of
won't change you've tried you know all
of these governments have tried
basically bribing people to have kids
you've got scandinavian countries that
are setting up the most amazing benefits
for people who have kids still they
don't want to have lots of kids um you
know china's kind of like pulled the
brake on it's one child policy and now
it's pulled the break of its two-child
policy and it's saying you know if you
want three that's fine you can have
three and they're talking about what the
world will be like
you know with this diminished population
what it means is you'll have a much
older population so you'll have far
fewer young people paying for a lot more
old people and they talking about some
interesting things that might happen
that you might possibly have a less
aggressive society because you'd have
fewer kind of young men you'd have more
all these just about the place but then
conversely you might have a lot more
very frustrated young men because you
know they they're just basically
spending their entire lives paying for
the pensions of the the people who went
before them and then this you know that
was an eight-page feature and then just
kind of condensing it to the basics you
just got a map of the world and you
color code it by the places that are
making babies at the sustainable rate
and those that aren't and it's
fascinating because the world is just
colored in you know like north america
most of south america all of europe
large swathes of asia
people aren't having babies at a
sustainable rate and it's going to shift
everything's going to change everything
you know you've got people like i think
taiwan's down at you know
just just above one you know that's
nowhere near enough for its population
to
sustain so that's going to have
interesting impacts in terms of
everything in terms of environment you
know it could be that the thing that
saves us is not technology it's not
people changing their lifestyles but
it's just that you know humans you know
the human population just starts to
wither away hopefully in time to
mitigate the worst excesses of
of of climate change maybe not
um you know yeah you might completely
have a sea change in your attitude
towards refugees you might start to
think that you really really really
needed them you wanted to welcome in
everything could change i just love that
you have a a double-page spread a very
simple map and hopefully you can spark a
lot of conversations around that very
easily people in chad
pumping out nearly seven
children
per woman
that's right but it's all still it's all
still trending down
is that right and then the bottom five
singapore at 1.16 the united arab
emirates at 1.14 so that's interesting
to me because both of those are very
wealthy countries
yeah super wealthy countries andorra
1.13 puerto rico 1.1 and taiwan at 1.06
yeah that's um i wouldn't have guessed i
don't know much about andorra puerto
rico but i wouldn't have guessed
singapore the united arab emirates or
taiwan to be in that bottom five
hmm i mean religion factors into it as
well of course as you have a kind of a
less religious society and you know the
the
religious strictures around you know
populating the earth and not using
contraception so as they fade away the
the real key thing or one of the real
key dynamics though is moving out of
villages because in villages everybody
knows you and you're under immense
social pressure to have kids
particularly if you know if there's a
level of kind of religiousness there as
well but when you move to the city
nobody knows you there's nobody sort of
saying oh you still no kids say oh oh
okay you know nobody's wagging their
finger plus also you can get you know an
education and you can move on with your
lives and it turns out that when people
do that they don't want so many kids
it's scary man when you think about what
the
development of birth control and the
decline of religion
those two things no one could have
predicted that that was going to mean i
don't know
does it look like the global population
is going to break 10 billion or will it
do you think it'll slow before that
so there's all sorts of different things
so i think the un one has us breaking 10
billion
this one that but actually i think to be
fair the u.n has got three different
scenarios okay yeah
and one of them has some [ __ ] loads
of [ __ ] less that's right yeah yeah
it's like a [ __ ] scale yeah um and uh
and yeah so and so and it you know it
it'll depend on on where we get to on
that's on that scale but yeah under some
scenarios you know in 20 years time or
so you start glance off the bottom of 10
billion or something like that and then
it never stops you know the decline i
mean presumably it stops when you get to
two people but you know we're like it's
or one person but it you know that
decline will continue because obviously
each generation shrinks you know there's
fewer people having fewer kids having
fewer kids
what's the solution to that does he
propose one
well i think that they um
i think in the book
they think that we don't kind of need a
solution we just need to be ready for it
you know so actually there'll be tons
and tons of benefits you know if indeed
the the population sort of you know
levels off and then starts to decline
quite rapidly
before we've totally
messed up the environment then that will
have incredible benefits like each year
there'll be fewer people consuming you
know the quality of life for the people
who remain
well i mean that's quite broad seeking
because obviously there's there's a lot
of implications about kind of a
dwindling adwinding society and having
fewer people to kind of do the jobs and
so on but but from an environmental from
a purely from a global point of view
actually the environment you know could
be a massive massive benefit that was
one of the big things they talked about
and they just said you know this will be
another thing that humans have to adapt
to but it's something that the bear's
thinking about yeah well i mean if
everything's going to become automated
and there's going to be no jobs for us
in any case if robots are going to take
over everything it doesn't matter
there's only going to be two people left
yeah i wouldn't because there must be a
there has to be a level that things
flatten out at that
or else we're talking about this is the
next big extinction event that imagine
imagine if we make it through
global pandemics
world wars
nuclear weapons we avoid destroying
ourselves we avoid all of the asteroids
and the fact that we're not [ __ ]
enough
annihilates the human race how did
that how did that civilization go
extinct oh they just got bored with sex
they just got bored with it and they
didn't do it enough and they they
that was it but here's another thing man
imagine
we could be living through
the period
where there are the most humans on the
planet that there will ever be oh yeah
oh yeah that that i mean that will that
will probably be another kind of like
thing to chalk up in our lifetimes but
then of course you know like making
predictions about these things
is kind of nonsense you can see where
the numbers are trending and so on but
also say the robots do take over and
we've got loads of notes and loads of
lovely spare time
do humans start to reorient their lives
again yeah i mean they don't need to
they don't need to work to provide you
know maybe they're living to 120. so
they could dedicate 30 years of their
lives just to study and maybe they can
have babies when they're in their 70s so
maybe that's the thing maybe you start
pumping out babies nobody foresaw the
[ __ ] revolution of the 2040s yeah
that's right led by 70 year olds yeah
left by randy 70 year olds you know on a
mission to repopulate the earth i mean
who knows who knows any of these things
i agree rob orchard ladies and gentlemen
an answer for everything 200
infographics to explain the world will
be linked in the show notes below where
else should people go if they want to
hassle your company on what it is that
you do
oh and so go to slow
slowdashjournalism.com
and find out all about the magazine and
subscribe for a very reasonable rate of
40 pounds a year and um come to some of
our events we do fantastic free events
where we do in-depth chats with
journalists about their stories
we really kind of get behind the scenes
of that come to one of our classes we'll
teach you how to make infographics we'll
teach you how to be a features writer
teaching you how to launch a magazine
you know any any number of different
things uh how to be a graphic journalist
um yeah um come along to one of those
and get the book it's do you want this
book this is your classic christmas book
it's 17 quid but it feels like it's
worth 25 which is nice you know it's got
heft to it it's got volume and um i kind
of picture myself
as i almost i'm you know wandering
around waterstones like i lost sheep on
the 23rd of december thinking i've got
to buy for all who am i going to buy
what am i going to get what do they even
like this is good because this has got
politics culture sport film you know
environment everything there's something
in there for everybody so it can look
like you've chosen it for just that
you'll be like yeah i saw they've got a
chapter on designer dogs and stuff like
that and i know you like dogs so here's
your christmas present so this is good
this is where we're aiming it's like
four four square in the center of that
you know like that panic buying
christmas market that's very well
thought out
yeah exactly
rob yeah thanks so much next time thank
you my cheers what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace